child protection authorities have begun
warning parents to keep their kids away
from squid game the korean drama is
netflix's most popular show ever drawing
130 million viewers in its first month
alone but
it's very violent the show reaches cash
strapped uh features crash-strapped
characters competing against each other
in various challenges for a chance to
pay off their debts if they lose they're
brutally executed
show is fiction but the games in it are
based on real children's games and some
observers say the violence is spilling
over into real life
well haley abeiro from dw culture has
been following this and is with me here
in the studio
what's the problem here why are child
protection authorities up in arms about
this show
well terry i don't know how well you
know the show yourself but it is very
very violent it's fiction obviously and
it's meant for adults but that
unfortunately has not stopped children
from gaining access to it now some of
the games the characters play in the
show are based on real childhood
playground games that are played all
around the world and there have been
reports that children are coming home
from school and telling their parents
that they've been playing squid game at
school obviously not in the classroom
but in the playground and reports from
many countries so in asia in europe the
us australia um i say that kids as young
as six years old have been spotted in
playgrounds adding a kind of cruel twist
to some of these playground games by
actually physically punishing the losers
and let me give you an example
one one game that's actually featured in
the show is a popular game called red
light green light it's also known as
grandma's footsteps in some countries
and i remember as what's the time mr
wolf you may have played it yourself
it's that game where you have a group of
children who have to creep up on another
child who's got their back turned and
when that child turns around they've got
to freeze and if they're caught moving
then they're out
and there have been reports that these
children are not just out they're
actually getting physically beaten up by
the other children as a kind of
punishment because these children have
been watching or have heard about squid
game
so authorities are concerned for reasons
you just mentioned and they i'm sure
would prefer that kids don't watch this
but can you really stop children from
watching a television show it's very
very difficult these days i mean it's
easier said than done netflix has rated
squid game 15 meaning obviously that
parents are advised not to allow their
children under that age to watch it but
if you think it also comes with a
warning i must say not just about
violence but even about sex about
suicide even
um it's being streamed in 130 million
households um around the world though
terry and that is going up every day so
as you can imagine it's very hard to
stop kids from somehow seeing this and
netflix of course has parental control
settings but they're pretty easy to
bypass if you know how and kids that are
not actually watching the show have been
picking up its messages from social
media platforms that are popular with
them like tick tock for example
um people have been posting um their own
versions of these games that are played
in squid game on tick tock and
challenging other users to actually copy
them and some of these videos have gone
viral
it's literally got so bad that primary
and elementary schools around the world
have been sending emails and letters to
parents saying please please check your
parental control settings on your
devices talk to your kids check what
they're accessing on social media
wow yeah um you know i haven't watched
it yet but i'm and i'm not sure i will
uh
anyway it's not for everyone i guess not
harley da barrow from dw culture thank
you so much
you